[Music]
hi there
my name is vincent
and i work as a research advocate at
raza at rasa we're working on open
source tools to allow you to write your
own virtual assistants
so a lot of our work involves a research
team one that i'm a part of and my job
is to make sure that the algorithms and
tools that we have inside of our
technology stack are well understood by
our community of developers
and as you can imagine in my day-to-day
work it is very important that i
communicate
concepts clearly
now communicating things clearly
in the age of remote work does mean that
it might be good to invest in some tools
so what i would like to do in this talk
is just give an overview of some of the
tools that i've picked up such that
hopefully you are also able to
communicate more clearly to your
colleagues and or to your community
so let's say that i'm making a video and
the point of this video is that i want
to explain code which is something that
i tend to do on one of raza's youtube
channels
well then
i can do a few things i can use my mouse
to say well
i'm importing a module over here and we
can pay our attention to some of the
numbers that are on display here
and although the mouse cursor works
quite well
one thing that we should acknowledge is
that the mouse cursor is quite small and
you really have to pay attention to
where the mouse cursor actually is
and that can be a drain on the attention
of people who are watching the video
so what i prefer to do is i prefer to
use this app that doesn't just let me
hover my mouse over something it also
allows me to effectively just draw
and there's a lot of benefits to this
notice that when i draw a box around
something that i'm importing it's a lot
easier to draw your attention to it
i'm also able to just squiggle under a
little bit of code to emphasize that
it's important
note that it's also possible for me to
draw some arrows
and what's really nice about this app is
that i'm able to draw a circle and after
a few seconds it goes away when i lift
my mouse cursor up
it's little things like this that can
really help capture people's attention
because it feels like i'm lecturing and
drawing on a whiteboard again
and it's that feeling of a whiteboard
that i think a lot of people are really
missing when they're collaborating real
time in an actual office
now the app that i'm using for this is
called screen brush
and here's the widget that pops up
whenever i hit alt tab on my machine now
i have a dual screen setup so typically
when i'm actually recording you don't
see this in display
but what's also really nice is that i
can toggle it on and off whenever i feel
like it
in general i think these squibbles are
perfect for what i'm usually trying to
do
but it is also good to observe that
there's also tools for like actually
drawing arrows
i can also draw boxes
and there's also an option to actually
write
some
text
another thing that's quite nice is that
i'm also able to draw in different
colors
so
for example right now the background is
white but if the background will say
darker then i can use maybe a green
marker to emphasize
something that you can look at
but
what's also a great feature is that
there's a shortcut that allows me
to keep my drawings intact
now pay attention to the stopwatch over
here and again notice that it's great
that i'm able to draw this arrow right
it's great that i can draw your
attention to this one particular part
but notice that when i press the f
button
on my keyboard that then
the hourglass here changes
and i also notice that if i move my
mouse cursor up
that the arrow is still there
not only am i able to draw attention to
something i'm also able to literally
draw over the entire screen
and that allows me to actually explain a
concept whenever i need it
very often when i'm talking about code
then i'm sometimes also talking about
other concepts that are happening in the
background
for example maybe i'm explaining that
we have a main rasa server that has to
communicate to a database via the rasa
sdk
and in this case i can
also explain that there's a separation
of concerns and
and explaining all of these concepts is
just a whole lot easier when you can
have both the code on display as well as
some of these other drawings
now what's also really great about this
app is that i can press ctrl z to my
heart's content so i can remove drawings
that i've made
and there's also some other useful
shortcuts as well
i'm able to
take things that i drew earlier and move
them around
i'm also able to use a scissors tool to
cut certain parts away
there's a lot to like here and what i
hope is clear is that the usage of this
tool isn't just limited to
explainer videos
this can also be great during zoom
meetings especially if you have a
one-on-one and you really want to get
down to some details being able to draw
is a very natural way to get ideas
across
but let's now talk about a very
human benefit of using this tool to
explain things what i'll quickly do is
i'll press w which is another shortcut
and basically this makes the whole
screen turn white so the screen actually
becomes a proper whiteboard i will now
also press f to make sure that my
drawings stay here but what i can do now
is i can say well let's talk about this
one concept
let's say that i want to explain an
architecture diagram
and
it's relatively simple so i've got a
rasa server over here that is dealing
with natural language processing tasks
let's say
and let's also assume that it has to
communicate with another back end
i will call this the rasa sdk
and it will be this service's job to
talk to databases
and
by drawing this like so i hopefully made
this distinction clear and the fact that
there's a separation of concerns let's
say
now
notice that because i'm drawing on an
actual whiteboard that i'm able to
explain a concept as i'm drawing
and this has one amazing benefit
the drawing
determines the pacing
you might recognize the feeling that you
can get when you see a powerpoint
presentation
where
big architecture diagrams are drawn in
one go
and it takes a while before you're
actually able to process what exactly
you're looking at because you're drawing
from scratch you are also forced to tell
the entire story as a presenter and it
also means that it's hard to go too fast
because you have to draw everything it
also means that concepts have to be
introduced one by one
which from a teaching perspective is a
great constraint to have
and hope it's easy to imagine that if
you force yourself to actually give a
presentation via whiteboard
that
the ideas tend to stick a bit more
because they've been properly introduced
because we're not going very fast
through all the different concepts
now note that another cool feature from
this package
is that the drawing that i just made
might be very conceptual
but if i now press alt tab again i'm
back into my code notebook
and if i want to go back to the concept
again i can now hit alt tab again and
the whiteboard just pops up again
i'm able to
make a drawing of something that we'll
keep in memory for a while that i can
refer back to
and that's also really great when you're
trying to explain something that you
know is very technical and perhaps also
very complex
now at this point you might be wondering
how is this guy
drawing so fast with his mouse cursor
and the truth is i'm not using a mouse
cursor i actually made the investment to
buy a
wacom tablet for this use case
there are a lot of these tablets out
there i believe you can also use your
ipad for this but i really like the
wacom tablet because it's really good
for just this one thing which is drawing
the tablet specifically is the wacom 1
which i believe is the cheapest one in
their line of drawing tablets where you
can see the drawing that you're making
but i don't want to suggest you need
this specific tablet there's also
cheaper ones out there
and the main goal here isn't to buy
fancy hardware it's just to be able to
make drawing a little bit easier because
drawings are just a great tool for
communication and i would like to give a
couple of examples where i've been able
to add drawings besides just in my live
videos to get concepts across better
so here's an example question from the
raza forum this is a place where our
community members can ask us questions
about anything related to raza
and there's a particularly good question
being asked here
it's about this machine learning model
that we've made and there's a user here
that's asking about details about this
very specific edge case where there's
only sparse inputs going in
and this is a great question
but how do you actually give a proper
answer to such a question
well
one thing that you can do is you can
grab the
architecture diagram which is what i'm
doing in my answer below here
and next what i'm doing is i'm taking it
apart i'm removing concepts that aren't
necessary so parts of the architecture
wouldn't be relevant
and again i'm able to highlight where
the developer needs to pay their
attention and it's this extra bit of
context that is very helpful
by having a drawing here that
specifically tells you what to pay
attention to will also tell you what i
am talking about so there's less noise
in the communication there's just a bit
more clarity
and
the nice thing about making drawings
like this is that if there's still
something that's not unclear
it's also easier to get a precise
question that is being asked and that's
actually what happened in this
conversation the user is now actually
using the same diagram that i made
to zoom in on a specific part of the
diagram and can therefore also request
my attention to go there
which is exactly what happened
i then also started zooming in on the
part below in this architecture diagram
i came up with a drawing that's served
as an example and then below i give even
more details
where we can talk about the precise
numerical operations that are happening
and what's great when this is on our
form is that
it's not just this one user who's asking
the question who will be helped by this
it will be our community at large
this answer will be saved for other
people to also enjoy and again i just
want to stress
what's really helping here is not just
the fact that i'm willing to give an
elaborate answer but also the fact that
i'm able to make these precise drawings
i really like to think that it's the
clarity that you get from a drawing
that's eighty percent of the result here
that's not to say though that a drawing
on its own is enough
it really also helps if you're able to
think about the story that the drawing
is supposed to tell
so let's now talk about a few examples
from documentation pages
what you're looking at here is the
github repository for an open source
project that i maintain on behalf of my
employer raza
now the goal of this project is to make
more natural language processing tools
available for raza
that support non-english languages
and there's a couple of tools that are
relevant
we have tokenizers for example
but
the downside of saying well i have
tokenizers
having tokenizers is great but maybe if
you're just starting out it will be nice
to remind people what a tokenizer
actually is
and for that the easiest thing you can
do is just add a little drawing
now there's a lovely little conscious
thing that does happen here though what
a tokenizer does is it takes a string as
input and it outputs a list of strings
as output
the idea is that a sentence goes in and
separate words go out
what some tokenizers are able to do is
do more than just split the text though
some of them are also able to
lemmatize
now the example that i have here shows a
sentence that is tokenized
and then the same sentence that is
tokenized and limitized what i'm going
for here is that because i have two
examples that use the same sentence that
there's also a very clear contrast
between the output
a user who's not familiar with
tokenization and limitization can look
at the drawing and start wondering well
what's different about the output here
and the hope is that by having a drawing
like this
we are able to give the user enough
intuition with a single example that we
don't have to fully explain what
limitization actually is
and notice that we do the same thing for
featurizers
and we also did the same thing for
fallback classifiers below here
adding some drawings to your
documentation can really also make it
easier for people that are perhaps
slightly less familiar with your domain
in our case natural language processing
but are still able to explore what the
package is about
what's really great about these drawings
is that you're able to get a concept
across without having to resort to
jargon
jargon is great but only if you're on
the inside of a domain for anybody
outside of a domain jargon can be rather
intimidating
and i would argue that adding drawings
can be a great way to alleviate this
what you're looking at here is an open
source package that i maintain
personally
the name of the tool is called clumper
and the whole point of it is that you're
able to more easily deal with large
chunks of json files
the library isn't doing something
particularly fancy but when you consider
all the operations that you might be
able to do on a json object i hope you
agree that it would be nice if we can
add a couple of drawings that explain
what's happening so if you go to the api
for every command that i have in this
library i've also added a drawing that
shows you what the
operation actually does
so for example let's go to the flatten
keys command
the drawing here shows the
representation of the data before and
after the operation
and i don't just have this for the
flattened keys method i pretty much have
a drawing for every method that is in
here
and again the whole point of this is
that we still add an example below so
you can in more detail confirm your
belief of what should be the output
but a drawing will just be so much more
intuitive because you can just eyeball
what's going to happen
and this is what i think contributes to
this package being easier to pick up
which is exactly what i'm trying to
achieve in my documentation
now i've given you all sorts of examples
for documentation and
i would like to think that these
examples are great when you're in
developer advocacy kinds of roles like i
am but i also want to emphasize that
being able to draw is great when you're
working on an open source project or
together with a colleague
here's an example of a issue in github
where i'm trying to explain what i think
a certain component in the machine
learning model should do
sure there's a lot of context in text
that will explain what exactly i'm doing
and why
but the awesome thing about having a
drawing again is that my colleagues and
collaborators
can more easily pinpoint where i might
be wrong and it just makes iteration
faster because we're spending less time
communicating because we only need one
or two of these pictures to get the ball
rolling on an idea
now in this case i'm showing
more the mathy parts of communication
but i would also argue that making some
of these drawings
they're also great for building user
interfaces
here i'm making a mental note for myself
for this user interface element that i'm
working on and i just want to highlight
the important parts
the thing that works really well for me
when i'm building ui components
is that the level of detail on a drawing
is
just right
i don't spend too much time making a
perfect drawing or a perfect photoshop
that's pixel perfect that someone has to
follow
but i am able to be expressive enough to
emphasize which parts are really
important
there definitely has to be a selection
element in my parallel coordinates chart
and i really want to attach color based
on the columns and it needs to be ui
element for that
and a drawing like this is enough to get
started quickly and iterate on
not too many details
and basically that whiteboard feeling is
something that you have again if you
just incorporate more drawings
and it's that feeling that i really like
having again especially when we are
doing remote work
now you might think at this point all of
this is great but do i really need to
buy a drawing tablet is that what i need
to do
well
maybe not
if you want to get started getting
clarity across the main thing that you
want to think about is just what picture
do i want to draw the main thing i'm
trying to do here is get the right
concepts across and i would certainly
argue that drawing definitely helps
but if you don't have a drawing tablet
maybe it's enough to
make some of these elements inside of
your favorite presentation tool
keynote google slides or powerpoint they
all have pretty good support to just
make some boxes with text appear in them
and that can already be sufficient to
get a pretty good drawing going simply
make a screenshot of all the components
that you're putting in here and that can
readily be shared inside of github on a
form or on slack
in particular if you're going down this
route there's also this other app that i
can really recommend
it's an app that i do pay for
and it's called noun project effectively
any kind of noun has a black and white
icon that you can just copy into a
presentation
so let's say that i'm interested in
doing something of a database
and sure this one looks nice i can just
drag it in
and use it
to my heart's content
in this talk i've been highlighting a
couple of tools
in particular i have my little wacom
tablet and i'm using an app called
screen brush right now but i hope that
there's also a lesson that i'm able to
get across that's a little bit more on
the meta side of the spectrum
these are just tools but the end result
is that we achieve clarity
if you're able to communicate clearly
there's less communication necessary and
you're typically able to just
get more done in your day
however if you want to achieve clarity
it does mean that you have to use some
of these tools
consciously you have to try to think
ahead and think well what kind of person
might see my drawing and what are some
of the more confusing concepts
the tools that i'm talking about here
are just tools in the end but the main
thing you want to
make a mental note of is that empathy is
actually maybe the first thing that
should pop into your mind
if you can really imagine what it's like
for someone not to understand the point
you're trying to get across then that
understanding is going to contribute
more to the clarity over here than any
of these tools will ever do on their own
having said all of this i do hope that
you give some of the techniques and
tricks that i've shown in this video a
try
especially in this era of remote work it
can really be helpful if we can just get
a bit more clarity and a bit more calm
in our day to day
i really like to think that the
techniques shown in this video
have made it easier for me to
communicate to my colleagues and to our
community over at raza but if you have
any questions about anything shown in
this video feel free to reach out